[Music]
dave karger here on fandango front
runners i'm joined by benedict
cumberbatch star of the imitation game
benedict one of the things that makes me
so joyful is when you do an impression
i've heard your alan rickman i've heard
your chewbacca i've heard your jar jar
i've heard your gollum
is there an impression of yours that you
love to do that i have not heard yet
i'll answer your question with uh a
question what time does sean connery go
and watch wimbledon i would love to know
tennis
um throw one at me and i'll have a go oh
my gosh um john cleese
simple
do it for you can you kevin spacey
i don't know what what kevin do you want
you want the kevin from seven
7-eleven kevin or do you want now is the
winter of our discontent make glorious
summer by this son of york hugh grant
last one uh gosh um in the words of um
flibberty tubit um what can i say um
it's raining i noticed um you're wet
my day is made
thank you for watching fandango
frontrunners
[Music]
you